[موسيقى]
احدى ابرز علماء الفيزياء في العالم
العالمه المصريه الامريكيه مها عاشور
ولدت في مدينه الاسكندريه في العام
وحصلت على درجه البكالوريوس من جامعه
الاسكندريه
حصلت على درجه الدكتوراه من امبريالندن
وعملت لاحقا في المركز القومي للاتصالات
في فرنسا
انتقلت لاحقا الى الولايات المتحده
وتحديدا ولايه لوس انجلوس حيث عملت باحثه
في معهد الجيوفيزياء والفيزياء الكوكبيه
في جامعه كاليفورنيا لتصبح استاذه في قسم
الفيزياء وعلم الفلك في الجامعه ذاتها
في عام
1999 اسست واصبحت اول مديره لمركز
الابتكار الرقمي بجامعه كاليفورنيا
كما قسمت في تاسيس مجموعه محاكاه البلازما
الفضائيه في جامعه كاليفورنيا وتم دعم
بحثها بمنحه من وكاله ناسا ومؤسسه العلوم
الوطنيه
كانت المحققه الرئيسيه في جامعه
كاليفورنيا في بعثه ناسا للغلاف
المغناطيسي المتعدد وشاركت في تاليف اكثر
من 270 مقاله بحثيه منشوره
تمت تسميتها زميله الجمعيه اليابانيه
لتعزيز العلوم وحصلت على وسام الخدمه
المدنيه المتميزه من الجيش الامريكي كما
حصلت على جائزه من وكاله الفضاء الاوروبيه
لمساهمتها في استكشاف الفضاء الجغرافي
باستخدام الكتله
منحت جائزه نساء العلم الامريكيات وتم
انشاء منحه دراسيه باسمها لدعم النساء
الراغبات في متابعه الدراسات العليا في
فيزياء الفضاء
توفيت بسرطان الكبد عام 2016
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات